okay
yeah
okay buddy all right thank you bye
sir
well you got your result
what do you think John
they're two sites do this one at a time
keep it quiet well
you need any help on the phone call away
all right thank you
the first ID location is 30 clicks when
I was driving on a straight track I
never reached a four Kinder Road and
bang a left excuse me sorry yeah what is
it honey I've used to fork in the road
my feeling is that the quickest route is
to turn right even though left is
shorter as the crow flies well quickest
way according to the map is not in the
last rainfalls most of the road on the
left got washed away
I guess so there's no Intel to confirm
more tonight
or how much time is that to the journey
about 20 minutes
30 tops
right so we got a plan
right is right
push that to the highest
foreign
[Music]
can you please stop the vehicle excuse
me I need to speak to you sergeant
vehicles to keep moving
I think we have a problem please stop
the vehicle charges
all vehicles are tactical stops
what is it Ahmed let's go something's
wrong there's no logical reason for
Hadith to lead us down this route unless
unless what
unless he's leading us into a trap
well that's a pretty big assumption on
it deduction not assumption
now you teaching me English
I've been thinking about all the
possible reasons why he'd take this
route all the answers smell bad
he lied about the road being washed out
the rainfalls didn't affect this area
but he's been vetted
can say whatever you want Sergeant we
just don't want to go down this road
you're out of your bounds Ahmed you're
here to translate
[Music]
actually I'm here to interpret
all right you want to be right on it hey
Jizzy check the drone on it JJ Tomcat go
up to the top of those rocks there and
tell me what you see
wiper sticks two Viper sticks too this
is Havoc three three
Roger we need live imagery now if I ever
stop
safe we're waiting for John
waiting to hear if there's a [__]
Ambush up ahead
I haven't got 10 minutes we need the
imagery now
all clear
Tomcat
all clear too
5462 imagery receive Havoc through three
out
[Music]
get that gun out of his throat
traitor I'll give a [__]
[Music]
up our position
take the gun out of his throat
[Music]
I am not gonna ask you again
[__]
[Music]
foreign
what the [__] is it
I was turning around get back to base
get in the truck
pick him up
[Music]